SIT BACK AND EBERLE AND ALL
ALONE, A SHOT, FORSBERG GETS
AND IT GOES OFF WATSON IN
THE KRAKEN ARE OFF GET
ACROSS.
IT WAS A GOOD ONE-TOUCH PASS BY
RASK IN THE SWEET SPOT. INSIDE
DRIEDGER.
THE  MINDED
GETS THE PUCK.
ZAITSEV, SHOT, STOPPED BYME, YE
TKACHUK'S  FORREATE A SPIN HERE
DRIEDGER.
GOES RIGHT UP OVER THE GLOVE
SIDE SHOULDER AND THEN, WATSON
WITH A GOOD JOB OFF.
McCANN, TO THE OUTSIDE OF ZUB.
HE WILL CIRCLE OLEKSIAK, SECOND
KUHLMAN.
IN AND HERE IT COMES.
WELL WIDE. LARSSON.
CHIP IN, MATTY
LOOKING, NOT TRYING LOOK FOR A
GOAL FROM THAT ANGLE.STERED BY .
AND OLEKSIAK, OFF KUHLMAN.OUTSI.
REALLY WANT TO GET ZONE.
GLOVE SIDE ON DRIEDGER.
HE IS ABLE TOT RIGHT
HERE. PICK UP THE CALL.
WHAT A GOAL!
BY  RACE HERE, HE GETS
THE PUCK BACK, DOESN'T GIVE UP
ON IT, AND A GOOD FAKE.
JARE
THE CORNER.